hi everyone I'm Eric Cohn and we're here
to discuss a scene from the Sun I'm
joined by the writer and director
Florian Zeller Laura Dern Vanessa Kirby
and Hugh Jackman thank you everyone for
being here so let's take a look at the
scene
um
sorry Kate's just here to talk to me
about
um Nicholas we just found out he's
hasn't been gone to school for almost a
month it's not only that Peter
he's not well
you need to speak to him I don't know
what to do anymore you just he needs you
Peter you can't just
abandon him not abandoning him why do
you keep saying these things just
I don't even remember what dick is
played out or something and
didn't me um
with uh
so much hatred
I thought I thought he was gonna
one
he scares me okay
[Music]
all right I'll uh
I'll I'll go see him tomorrow I'll swing
by at the end of the day
one of the things that I think we should
talk about with this scene is that you
really get a sense of the full scope of
what this film is trying to Encompass
dramatically so Florian can you tell us
about why you chose this scene to sort
of establish the dynamic of the film it
is the almost the first scene of the
film and it's a long conversation it's a
long scene but somehow they don't say
what should be said and we see for the
first time uh Peter Hugh Jackman's
character with his uh new life and the
baby they have together and suddenly his
previous wife knocking at the door to
ask for help and so we see this man
struck between you know his past and his
presence and we understand that he's
going to be about you know how to deal
with the present and the past and the
guilt that comes with this kind of
complex situation in family so you can
you talk a bit about figuring out what
needs to be conveyed in this scene given
that there are so many different layers
going on here yeah uh I mean the movie
itself really allows an audience to
understand what it's like for everybody
around someone who's going through a
mental health crisis so it's sort of
fitting in this first scene that you
have three of the major players who are
having to deal with this crisis in one
scene and for my character there's
certainly a sense that there is a lot of
unresolved history I think particularly
between Kate and Laura's character and
mine and as Florian said there's this
character spent a lot of time
not saying the thing that's really that
they want to say or that is on their
mind and so now
out of the blue his ex-wife comes
and that's difficult for him because
he's obviously trying to negotiate his
wife and her feelings and the feelings
of his ex and then
she's bringing up the a real genuine
difficulty with their son
which obviously becomes a crisis so as
the scene evolves there's so many things
at play and so many conflicting things
going on inside of Peter as an actor as
a gift it's a beautiful scene and it
happens in many scenes in this movie
where there is
a desire for things to work out but
there's just so many conflicts and
obstacles in the way and that's why I
thought he was interesting to shoot that
scene you know at the door you know uh
we don't know exactly if we are inside
outside and what is everyone's position
to me the set here plays also a role to
to you know to describe without telling
too much the dynamic and the difficulty
of every character is in this uh
triangle and I think in terms of the
very first conversation around our son
and this human beings Mental Health
crisis she never is able to really say
what's happening and with I think a lot
of Shame and confusion she admits that
her own child is scaring her which adds
to blame and you feel all the
expressions of the one thing we're not
talking about which is the actual need
of the boy Vanessa in your in your case
I'd love to hear a bit about what it was
like for you to be sort of hovering on
the outside of the dynamic between this
ex-couple and obviously having a very
key role to play in his character's life
but also realizing that this is
something that you have to be aware of
too I think that was the challenge for
everybody is so much of what you're
relaying on the external isn't actually
what's true on the internal and that
that was the position Florian was asking
of all of us to be in because it's so
much about how these humans can't
express something that's very true and
deeply deeply painful ones Laura said
maybe you know shameful
um but if they had what would have
happened if they'd been able to I think
that's the question and the reason why I
wanted the film to start with that scene
with the the three characters in The
Landing is also because it's like a like
a red arring in a way because it's it's
a lot about the divorce it's a lot about
the new family situation
as if it was the the whole problem but
and and uh Nicholas with the the
teenager dealing with depression I keep
mention keeps mentioning the divorce as
the reason why he feels the way he feels
and because everyone feels guilty uh
they all feel this is their fault
because you know they probably did
something wrong as a parent you can you
talk a bit about finding the right uh
kind of emotional level in this scene
and throughout the film because on some
level there's a kind of almost a passive
aggressive quality to this character
where he's trying not to lose his cool
but at the same time he knows he's lost
a lot of control over the situation
finding the right kind of happy medium
you know what was that process like for
you particularly at the beginning of the
story I see Peter as someone who really
genuinely believes he can
compartmentalize his life his work life
his son I think it's beautiful the way
it's set right at the boundary of his
new life behind the door and you see him
sort of go to close the door or I'm
going to deal in this no man's land of
the landing here you know outside the
apartment with his ex-wife and you see
the beginnings of that unraveling and
then I think the beauty of the story
what Florian wrote is
maybe the audience before him can see
him the water is rising around him and
even when he believes he's in control of
it he's he's slowly going underwater we
made the decision not to rehearse and I
felt strongly that it would be more uh
interesting for all of us not to know
before we are doing it what we were
doing and to discover the emotions on
set and the fact that it's characters
that are trying to control the
situations and to fix the situations I
thought that not to be in control of the
situation would allow all of us to be
connected with these true emotions it
was really an extraordinary process to
me to watch and to attend Vanessa I
wanted to ask you about the process of
listening and observing and obviously
you do a lot of that in the scene but
also a lot throughout the film and I
wonder what that process is like of just
sort of making sure that you're not
passively watching but you're sort of
actively processing the situation I mean
it was my biggest challenge for sure to
think something but nobody able to
express it and tried the best of ability
not to portray it either because you
have to be supportive but that
frustration I think becomes ours I think
as a viewer because sometimes we are
also in that position we want to say
don't do this or don't say that and and
this is what I wanted the audience to
experience because the the beginning of
that process is the the conviction that
there are so much ignorance and so much
shame and guilt around these topics
mental health issue and I really wanted
it was our way to open a conversation
about it and I wanted the audience to to
feel it from the from the inside through
through your your character I wonder how
acutely as actors you feel these
emotions on set and bring yourself in
and out of them being able to put
yourself in the skin of a character like
this must be incredibly challenging
emotionally and I wonder if you can talk
a little bit about how you slip in and
out of those feelings so that you don't
obviously have to take them home at
night in the way that these characters
do we took this yeah it could be home
every single night didn't we I mean even
when we tried not to it was with us the
whole experience because globally
we are in a mental health crisis I've
become more of a hot mess I think that
I've ever been in my life I wasn't
sleeping very well I it was fascinating
how it started to uh affect me more
maybe than any other film that I've done
and I was with you on that in that last
scene when he just breaks down and I
mean he went there so many times and
every single take he would just go there
it was just a privilege and all I could
do was just try and hold space and
and be there and I wanted to comfort him
you know as the character and and also
me because he was so so brave it's just
always such an honor to see someone
go there with their work and then sing
the whole movie like that it was just
was really masterful
and Florian what's it been like for you
to watch the film with different
audiences knowing obviously what's in
store but also seeing the response from
the crowd I mean the whole point of
making a film is to share that moment
with the audience we are not doing a
film just for ourselves but to to tell
to tell something and to share something
so it's powerful to me to to feel the
audience responding because it's it's a
sad story it's a tragedy but it's not
about trying to tell a sad story for the
sake of telling a sad story there is
something I hope uh cathartic about it
and that make you remember that we are
part of something bigger than ourselves
which is a humanity and this is a bit
what I felt uh Adventist when we were
all together with the audience really
I know in connection with us I would say
well thank you all for being here it's a
lovely conversation thank you